they're they're changing the rules so
that you know they're they're rigging
the game against against the Democratic
process does that inspire you does it
inspire you a little bit that that's
what's going on like you know I I have
the same program you do yeah just live
one day at a time yeah keep doing the
next right thing yeah and you know
trying to maintain kind of my intercom
and not um and not you know if God wants
me right to
win I'm going to win I just got to keep
doing the right thing and nothing could
stop me in that case that's such a great
Point man so I I feel like I mean I go
to a meeting every day on I'm on the
road I'm in a different city every day
and that's the one thing I always do wow
and I um bit of some good ones recently
anywhere particular that kind of stood
out I went to one in Maine that was
pretty cool a few months back I got n
and the guys was like this and our no I
yeah I went to one the other day where
uh it was a guy and first of all I want
to one in Barbados one time where they
were they were talking no beer for me
man they were talking about it was a
like a nightset meeting and they were
talking about how to take curses off of
people oh damn that's
crazy and I went to one in Belfast
during the war there which was really
interesting oh wow yeah but I went to
one the other day and they were um it
was and I went to this it was in New
Hampshire and they were they were um
uh and that the people I've been to a
couple times and they and the people in
that meeting recognize me they know I am
most of
them and it's it's a very supportive
atmosphere for me you know I don't know
whe they're Republicans Or democrats but
anyway it's very it's a very warm safe
kind of
place and um I Heard a guy there was a
break they take at those meetings up in
New England they take a f minute
cigarette break halfway with the meeting
yeah and uh it's from like the old old
days yeah and they uh this guy was
sitting like four or five seats behind
me and he he's you know one of these old
people who talks really loud cuz he's
going deaf yeah and he's uh you know
they compensate by talking super loud
yeah yeah and he was saying uh he was
saying RFK
Jr and he had three or four of his
cronies around him talk and they were
whispering to him you know that's RFK J
here and he said he's the
anaxa and I you know I was just listen I
was like you know I can hear what you're
saying yeah some senior citizens their
whisper gets a little a little high high
in the whisper and then he when he did
speak at that meeting and he spoke about
you know how important it was to get
your jab and stuff and um and I could
tell it was directed sort of you know
clearly was directed toward me but I'm
you know I feel like peaceful and and
afterward I went up and you know talk to
him said hi and
and and smile
but I you know it makes me I my job is
to stay sort of peaceful and Serene and
um and not and anything that I've ever
done in my life that is enduring that is
important uh um has come out of you know
that spiritual place and anything that I
do that comes from frenetic
activity is uh you know it's just
wormwood and bile I know um what was
what was one thing that so Bri we're
both sober so what was one thing that um
sobriety kind of adjusted or changed in
your for you in your life that you
didn't expect maybe what was something
that came out of it or being a part of
it or around
it
well it changed everything in my life
because I think before I came in I was
just like a bundle of appetites you know
and that's when you're you're kind of
living uh according to self-will and you
know it's like whether it's you know
drugs or alcohol or sex or extreme
Behavior or just you
know I was always just filling that
empty hole inside of me with with things
trying to fix that by reaching for
things outside of myself and my mind is
like a formulation Pharmacy I can turn
anything into a
drug and um you know
uh and then um and then trying to uh
adjust your compass so that you're you
know you're not living for self-will but
you're trying
to um do the next right thing and and
you know be of service to
others um and that you know that that is
what you know when I I was a when I I I
feel like I was born an addict I feel
like I had just an empty hole inside of
me from when I was a little kid and you
don't think so you don't think it was
something really that caused it when you
look at I don't think so but you know
and you hear in the program all the time
like half the people think they were
born with it and others just think that
you know trauma you know had something
to do with it but you know I also I I
there's certain races like the Irish mhm
that are oh yeah what we know yeah
there's other ones too they're the most
thirsty yeah the Irish yeah I mean
they're good at they make it look good I
mean for I mean we call it the Irish flu
yeah because it it
uh it's was it you go into a meeting and
you know yeah in any meeting any place
in the country and half the people in it
are you know Sullivan on O'Brian and oh
yeah a lot of Irish yeah um was there
was there were there was alcoholism in
your family was it popular in my
mother's family it was back to the
Neanderthals W they were all you know
and of all of my mother's siblings she
was the only one that did not get it and
U wow that's a lot then that's pretty
strong yeah it's just it's it's good to
have a program man I think it adds a lot
I think it's definitely been a Saving
Grace for me uh for sure just the people
I get to meet like last night a guy
texted me a new a new guy been texting
in in the in the rooms and we're texting
and he he hit me up yesterday I was like
hey you want to go to a meeting I wasn't
going to go you know so next thing you
know I go and we're like over in Venice
and it's 8:00 p.m. we're sitting on a
porch at some guy's house you know
listening to a guy talk about how he was
in a gang and his brother uh got killed
right next to him you know and uh and
how for years he was using and then
finally he started to get help and got
in the program and just but to sit there
and hear a story like that was real
that's part of the fun of going to the I
mean it just puts something real in your
life it's like I left out of there like
sure you know it was very sad but it was
like a real thing it was like I left out
of there with like I don't know it just
people sharing makes you feel more
connected you know but you know when you
uh when you got sober did you real did
you because a lot of I know a lot of
comics feel like you know that the
alcohol and the drugs are part of what
makes them funny
did you and that they have anxiety about
getting sober because they think it
might
hurt yeah I think I had some of that for
sure you know I was in and out for a
long time I had three years sober and
then I was in and out and then finally I
just was so spiritually just empty you
know i' gotten a decent amount of
popularity and I thought that that would
achieve my happiness or it would do
something for me and it just didn't do
anything it was like literally getting
to a top of a mountain and or you know a
decent LED Ed on a mountain and you're
like dang I'm still on a mountain you
know that's what it felt like and so I
think that just made me realized that
there was something bigger going on
inside of me that I had to get some help
for um and then just the gifts of it
like seeing other people get well like
seeing people's lives turn around like
just it's it's cool I can go to a place
every day I can go somewhere and witness
a miracle almost and that's unbelievable
you know people are looking for miracles
and reasons to make them feel you know
and so I think that's one of the reasons
I go to is because there it makes me
feel in there you know like regular life
it was always trying to find something
to make me feel and I could never I
couldn't do it there wasn't anything
that was doing it enough but man I go in
there and I see somebody their life has
changed and man it makes me feel you
know and that's really what I've always
been looking for I've just been wanting
to feel and that's probably one of the
most blessings of it and then just
getting to meet cool I mean like you
know you and I I have so many most of my
friends are sober yeah you know it's
kind of C it's just how it kind of works
out and also some of them used to be the
biggest derx so you get to hang out with
the craziest people in the world you
know I mean alcoholics are are generally
kind of Desperados yeah oh they're
interesting